It turns out that all four of these problems
can and have been tackled using mapreduce. Chevron utilizes the
mapreduce programming model to sort and process data from
ships that search the ocean for seismic activity indicative of
oil reserves. Tons of online commerce sites, eBay for
one, use mapreduce to manage their huge amounts of data
on sellers, buyers, and transactions. Some companies use mapreduce
to process data to identify malware and cyber attack patterns.
A company called IPTrust for example used mapreduce to
assign trustability scores to IP addresses. Finally products developed
by a company called Apixio leverage mapreduce to analyze
large amounts of data and help healthcare professionals answer questions
about their patients health. As you can see mapreduce
can be applied to a solve a wide range of
problems. I'm sure you're anxious to use mapreduce to
solve our problems so let's discuss how the mapreduce programming
model actually works.